ragazzi miei siamo tornati su minecraft
alcun episodio five con pietro e
stavolta non c'è comunque speranza per
pietro però vabbè godetevi il video sei
caduto in avanti a livello è facile ma è
un posto
capisco le ninfee sento chi l'acqua
ripartirà li darei parti all'inizio
ok vai avanti avanti non è difficile ho
fatto tutta la prima bozza credo operano
troppo presto realtà spettacolo molto
bene non è l'inferno ma dove diavolo si
finica sto facendo tutto giusto quindi
non mi sto mai fermando sto giocando
giusto oggi
mammamia tutto il livello pensa questa è
veramente l'aspide runner livello speed
runner cioè non sbagliato niente stava
nulla ma allora io la farei li invitano
gli stati di uno slam ho capito che ti
si è bloccato senza manco guardare
guardali che è provata sblocca un coso
ma non ancora finito sono diventa quanto
dura ma basta ok ok ok ok mi sa che
desse l'ultima il battitore di livello
se sbaglio qualche autobus dove sei tu
guarda barca vacamòra le serre ne sono
così no no no mezzo cuore non ci stava
morendo mezzo cuore ma salvatori di
particolari inizio dovevo calmarci
qualche parte difficile e livello 51
alfa haider a metà strada mi ha detto
bravo bravo bravo bravo
mamma mia sto cadendo e ce la fa il
primo tentativo volta player buono a
player vai vai 52 ora devi arrivare
bravissimo dai sono stati forti ragazzi
sono stati poi vediamo
no no dai non lo si muore leccarsi è
così devi fare se non ti spingeva la
mano e anche divertente
quasi vai ma tu non mi sono salvato
nello stesso punto tour ha detto no
cadeau come lui
e invece no molto bene sono fiero di me
stesso solo a volte bravo 53 euro
lo fa non finisce non mi ricordo dove si
può andare bene che sto ancora entrato
qualcuno che giocarono fortissimo sono
forti sono al mio che ideò cadore è che
il giocatore cavalli così bravo da ecco
c'è una freccetta lì che ci indica della
freccetta sembra messi male potevi
buttarmi giù non l'hai fatto si è
diventata una persona buona oggi
bravissimo e non lo so l'ho visto adesso
perché adesso non sono più andato avanti
music italiana lo stato in turismo hai
visto stata un'ora
viva i terra piatti sti della terra è
rotonda perché i cubi di minecraft sono
piatti risotto madonna madonna l'ultimo
salto e lo fa 54º livello ciao amico
vediamo al prossimo gioco
oddio proprio casinò pietro ti prego
vieni bravo sei stato breve
guarda ti prego tv butto indietro no no
no no mamma mia che maggio gioco di me
sembra che la jones pantana d'antan
parla tanto dei pirati dei carabi dato
sta discutendo aspetta ok è bellissimo
col nostro se puoi toccare la co meno io
non la tocco per sicurezza però va
meglio ma poi che cosa vedo tra cosa
avete voi la mia visuale a una idea poi
qua è un casino
mammamia pietro un casino po affidati ok
sono arrivato fino alla fine occhio che
se cadi qua carini nuovo devi far tutto
di no faccio bayrou io ti aspetto c'è
praticamente siamo caduti e ci state
no
guarda che se non riesco a ce l'ho fatta
amico sono forte vieni qua mi pare che
esistono i tagli in editing sono ciao
sono senza pensato al kurd senza tagli
ma speed questore dv8 redivivo per
singolo episodio e la facciamo tutto
alla volta tutte la prima le facciamo
quindi non in senso verrebbe comunque
tipo dito decise uguale a quello che sa
se le banche non sarebbe molto corto gli
alieni vieni mio proprio io forte io
posso ieri stamattina che mangiato pane
park una colazione pane parkour come
tutte le volte in cui iniziamo le p come
faccio da lì avevo sei passato ho fatto
uno slide occhio bravissimo sono
fortissimo perfetto ho fatto cose amico
guarda chi c'è il corso due erano
partiti esattamente dove siamo partiti
siamo alla stessa altezza di dove
eravamo quando siamo partiti da me daina
va avanti quindi se andiamo avanti
ancora un po superiamo all'altezza del
primo episodio nuovi episodi per
riuscire a fare sta roba
quanto agli episodi siamo live view
seguimi fratello lava ha un sapore
pietroso oggi c'è dell'acqua ma si dai
livello 56 per immagini che l'acqua di
portata sarebbe stata una roba veramente
orribile
se io avessi fatto se livelli l'avrei
fatta una roba del genere allora visto
schiantarti posa
non ha neanche visto questa pianta tutto
livello deve fare perché è bello lungo
via abbastanza liscia lo slime fa che
arriva più tardi vi è bravo bravo
insegnami a me come charlize line eccolo
ora che mi sa che arrivi di quest'opera
è oggi possibile ogni volta che mi
raccomando stai attento buon morto
mi raccomando pietro fuori bene e gli
averi che riesce a fare la speed run 57
ti aspetto no visto che questo è uno di
quelli che dobbiamo saltare amico è
quello e unico livelli che non possiamo
fare
sì sono quelli che tipo verdi che però
non parte niente non so perché siamo al
58 my friends però non capisco che è
perché devi fare così in parte
l'anti dei trasporti se no mica ora è
fatto la sua casetta mi sembra molto
tranquillo sto livello che strano però
se delle case per rappresenti a devi
fare le canna parkour ma ben mamma mia
ragazzi lavoro è una mia impressione
stop al cultura veramente tipo il doppio
degli altri
bravissimo non l'avevo visto mai mai mai
ne sarei accorto bravissimo amico che è
forte e abbiamo stato non mi recherò
pace da entrare nel ovviamente nel muro
ci sono devi entrare nel quadro esatto
ma di un quadro entraci che di solito è
sempre quello ma che figo guarda la
sostanza amico io non solo ma cretino
oddio cos'è cielo teletrasporto siamo
molto più in alto works e lo so
figo strano che funzioni tutti in questa
mappa tranne per i livelli di prima
questo è difficile l'accordo di questo
non so cosa sia ma laddove da che parte
da qua sotto e nora sopra ma sopra di
farlo sopra e puntare tipo questo coso
qua
ok oppure l'altro mi vuoi loro hanno un
problema
ciao 59 ma tu allora amico potrebbe
potrebbe esserci un altro problema
mi sa che l'obiettivo eccolo centrata
sono sotto promessa che dunque non lo
riusciamo a fare questo perché c'è un
pezzo che fai con l'europa
ma lei per secoli europei verdi
rischiamo dai no si va ora a 139 siamo
cinquantanove ok molto bene sto giocando
veramente bene ragazzi non so però dove
stiamo andando a finire dovrei aspettare
pietro faccio salto l'aspetto perfetto
non è vero scherzo vado avanti
perfetto il cavo molto bene ma è
facilissimo cosa c'è di strano
ah ok adesso forse non lo è mamma mia
26 madonna se di sandra lo score ciao
dove ai fatti arriva alla nona di fare
giro che figata
ma dai può capitare di noceto ritorna
per averla le dico ok arrivo qua chi
cacchio sono fatta è stato mi sono
cagato addosso però sono fatta vieni
ciao
no no no che c'è stato difficile ok
ecco da qua c'è la parte in cui torrente
ne andremo arrivare alla fine ski
parliamone non ce ne siano tante liste
particola perché mi dispiace ski parler
però non so che bovo
ciao amico i'm arriving my friend is not
my friends who you are my brother my
friends o molto bene fortissimo bene
molto bene
perfette per aver ragione questo si sta
roba qua c'è scritto che la lava no no
no no forse volta ci pensi otto volte
prima di fare una roba del genere ecco
qua è difficile qui avrei bisogno del
tuo aiuto sincera vendola ma allora qua
io credo di dover centrare se quello che
penso esatto ecco forse sommare a quello
bene che si era fatto bene poiché
proprio no ti prego
io sono una persona che a culo nella
vita soprattutto mi ha dato una trina
mandato ancora più in alto quindi sarò
la potremmo sfruttarlo ma davvero te lo
giuro buttarti giù invece sono andato
più in alto ancora te lo giuro che è
arrivata la lava ma se io muoio che
succede ma mai per cosmai mi perdo non
ho capito e mi sa che ho aperto uno slam
si perché prima non c'era così anche se
moriamo in teoria possiamo buttarci su
science e lodato dice sì se fai un salto
allucinante ma se ti fai più volte di
slimer si fa sulla porta addirittura
cose poi se poi vuoi vedi che quando non
puoi tirarli giù questi quindi sono di
ferro quelli di legno poi tirarli giù se
non li faccia difetto si sa bene è
capitolato the year livello 61 61
l'acqua se no che l'ha con tutti
trasporto e donne 60 one allora spetta
questa parte un casinò dove sono salire
uno scalino
ma è il problema è come se ci avessero
buttati giù per poi farci risalire in
altri livelli consueti siamo sempre
andando sempre più in alto capito
alla fine mi potrei bello è il culmine
dell'alto sei morto porco pure nuovo
altissimo tutti in un colpo lo fa
facendo oggi ce l'ho fatta sono sopra ai
cactus
poi dopo è però boh io al massimo sono
arriva a 6 dai carc ma che come faccio a
cadere da lì sono in cima in cima c'è
finale si è 60 porca vacca sto cadendo
62 sono poi ci stiamo avvicinando alla
cima
che bella
da questa qua e poi scendiamo è anche
punto peschi bari scuse
qui sotto puoi fare vedi la vedi lacune
non mi sembra proprio a vero io sono
strumenti che trasporta dice ci provo io
l'ho preso per grande sì under gangai ho
saltato di pe però non so dove adesso
non so dove davanti dove pietro che non
solo bisogna andare avanti ma immagine
da qua mezzo cuore loro mamma mia la 36
latina scoppola però so che ci rimette
celate c'era una a scendere io non torno
più io sennò non ho detto che ci sono
mille strade non capisci mai quale devi
prendere questa volta dopo vieni amico
lo porta c'è un portale lì c'è un
portale sono arrivato al portale vieni
perché no 60 ancora non è finito 63
sempre per 63 62
porca vacca tocchi ai se tocchi
l'ossidiana ti delle trasporta carina
dove è dall'inizio a ok no pensavo a
queste mai craf harcourt
ci pensi ci pensi se fanno la tipo in
getting over almeno a livello finale
però lo fanno
mamma mia se ci pensi veramente da
buttare gioco problema non esista lo
richiede ai soldi alla voce non open
sono nomi ma prima non si possa sia
illegale fa effetto perfetto comunque il
più bel parco che abbia mai visto
attenzione queste per te amico prego
anno se neanche partito
eccolo e va al 64 in 3 2 1
non è vero una finito di livello ma ti
giuro tema
a proposito se cado poi riparto da zero
no non riportino ripartirà questo
pensate ora che casino per ripartire da
qua o non usare e immagino che
primaverili alla punta più sarà
difficile perché è una certa tipo
cattiva tipo che cade nei livelli quelli
piccoli nuovo dai non si torna indietro
di dieci livelli perché sulla punta
con cui ho fatto tutto sto casino ancora
sto qua ok qui d'acqua devi fare tutto
un giro a noi c'è una porta e va beh ok
ok 64 che casino vieni con noi o con
questi dirigenti non giuro sul mio
futuro
te lo giuro non ti tiro giù perfetti
giovane prossima volta che ne avrò la
possibilità ti spacco in due ragazzi
michael cohl finisce qua continua il
prossimo episodio spero vi sia piaciuto
come al solito ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto lasciato un bel commento è un
bel haj anche i vari sensori come la
descrizione se non sapersi di schiavi
come sempre ci vediamo al next video
volo tira la testata ma sono troppo
lontano facciamo così
[Musica]